y
[Música]
el presidente de colombia se dio la
presión en las calles y retiró su
proyecto de reforma tributaria sin
embargo organizaciones sociales
sindicalistas e indígenas anuncian que
las huelgas continuarán hay cerca de mil
denuncias contra la fuerza pública
tenemos información con nuestro enviado
especial
organizaciones internacionales y el
gobierno de eeuu condenaron la
destitución del fiscal general
salvadoreño y de los magistrados de la
corte suprema que habían protagonizado
encuentros con el presidente en allí
bukele cataloga en la medida como una
vulneración a la división de poderes
este lunes 3 de mayo se conmemora el día
mundial de la libertad de prensa
revisamos la situación de los
periodistas y el ejercicio de su
profesión en el mundo la ong reporteros
sin fronteras asegura que cada vez es
más difícil sostener este trabajo como
bien común
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
colombia la presión ciudadana llegó al
presidente iván duque a retirar el
controversial proyecto de reforma
tributaria que generó multitudinarias
manifestaciones en su mayoría pacíficas
sin embargo varias ciudades están en una
crítica situación de orden público
la ong temblores contabiliza al menos 14
muertos y ha recibido 940 denuncias de
abuso policial pese al retiro del
proyecto de ley los manifestantes
aseguran que seguirán en las calles
buscando frenar otras normativas que
vulneran sus derechos pero también
condenar el actuar de las autoridades
cali en el suroccidente del país
concentra la mayor tensión y la ciudad
está militarizada conectamos con nuestro
enviado especial
luís muñoz luis buenos días como amanece
cali y que responden las autoridades
locales y nacionales ante las graves
denuncias que hacen varias ong
buenos días desde cali valentina en la
ciudad trata de recuperar la normalidad
y tanto es así que la alcaldía ha pedido
que este lunes sea una jornada cívica
cívica de hecho acá destacar que el
propio alcalde jorge iván ospina va a
participar en una marcha pacífica que
trate de devolver la normalidad a la
ciudad después de varios días de bloqueo
que han dejado imágenes de
desabastecimiento en gasolineras pero
también en supermercados y bancos
las marchas comenzaron el pasado
miércoles 28 de abril y aunque sí que es
verdad que ha habido enfrentamientos
entre policía y manifestantes y
altercados la verdad es que la mayoría
de manifestantes han salido de forma
pacífica lo que también es verdad es que
como bien decías organizaciones de
derechos humanos y sociales han
denunciado que cerca de 1000 personas
han podido resultar heridas y más de una
decena de muertos no ante esto la verdad
es que no ha habido una respuesta del
gobierno pero sí que la defensoría del
pueblo ha celebrado una reunión en la
que han asegurado que van a seguir de
cerca todas las marchas y las acciones
policiales y por su parte la
procuraduría del estado ha asegurado que
la presencia de militares en las calles
no debería producirse
louis porque continuará el paro pese a
la retirada
tributaria
para buscar esas claves creo que es
importante ver la mina no la minga
indígena que llegó el domingo a cali y
que este lunes van a hacer una rueda de
prensa en la que van a analizar y
declarar informar cuáles son las
siguientes pasos con la duda que hay de
si finalmente querrán desplazarse a
bogotá sin embargo ya lo han asegurado
en un comunicado lo que quieren ahora es
la renuncia del presidente de banc duque
una sintonía similar a la de los
manifestantes nuestra experiencia estos
días en las calles nos ha hecho ver que
que no es sólo la reforma tributaria lo
que ha hecho que despierte esta ira en
colombia sino que también hay otros
proyectos de ley como la reforma de
salud que nos gustan entre los
manifestantes u otras quejas que es el
aumento de la pobreza también la
reanudación de la expresión con un
linfocito para erradicar cultivos de
coca o también la sistémica asesinato de
líderes sociales que vive el país
y después muchas gracias por toda esta
información estaremos muy pendientes de
lo que ocurra en las próximas horas en
colombia vamos ahora hasta el salvador
la oea human rigths watch y la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos entre
otros rechazaron la decisión del
congreso salvadoreño de destituir a
magistrados de la corte suprema y al
fiscal general funcionarios que habían
tenido choques con el presidente en allí
bukele y habían criticado su gestión
las organizaciones encienden las alarmas
sobre intentos de concentración de poder
y rechazan lo que catalogan como una
vulneración a la división de poderes por
su parte la vicepresidenta de eeuu
kamala harris mostró su preocupación por
la situación en el país
tenemos una profunda preocupación por la
democracia del salvador a la luz de la
votación de la asamblea nacional para
destituir a los jueces de la corte
constitucional un poder judicial
independiente es fundamental para una
democracia sana y para una economía
fuerte este lunes 3 de mayo se celebra
el día mundial de la libertad de prensa
coincidiendo también con el aniversario
número 30 de la declaración de winehouse
de 1991 precursora de esta celebración
la unesco tomó para este año el lema la
información como bien común un hecho que
según un informe de la ong reporteros
sin fronteras cada vez es más difícil de
sostener debido al retroceso de la
libertad de prensa a nivel mundial
este 3 de mayo se cumplen 30 años de la
declaración de wing fuck realizada por
periodistas de medios africanos en 1991
esta declaración toma su nombre de la
capital de namibia sólo dos años después
en 1993 la propia unesco declaró el 3 de
mayo como día mundial de la libertad de
prensa pero 28 años después de la
declaración la libertad de los
informadores para ejercer su profesión
está sufriendo un paulatino deterioro
según la ong reporteros sin fronteras el
73 por ciento de los 180 países que
analiza cada año tiene la libertad de
prensa total o parcialmente bloqueada el
ejercicio del periodismo principal
vacuna contra el virus de la
desinformación encuentra graves
impedimentos en 73 de los 180 estados
del ranking establecido por reporteros
sin fronteras y obstáculos en otros 59
destacan por la buena calidad de su
libertad de prensa noruega finlandia y
suecia mientras que en el fondo de la
lista encontramos a türkmenistán corea
del norte y eritrea como países con
menor libertad de prensa este año además
son ya ocho los periodistas asesinados
en cumplimiento
según la ong los últimos los españoles
david beriáin y roberto fraile en
burkina faso recientemente se han dado
casos también de arrestos de periodistas
en mianmar tras el golpe militar y el
enjuiciamiento en hong kong de la
periodista para ocho y por supuesta
realización de declaraciones falsas
desde la fundación para la libertad de
prensa se denunciaron el domingo
agresiones contra periodistas en
colombia durante las recientes protestas
en la flip conocimos 18 agresiones
contra la prensa en el contexto de las
manifestaciones del primero de mayo la
fuerza pública nuevamente fue el
principal agresor el informe de
reporteros sin fronteras muestra que los
indicadores de libertad de prensa
empeoraron por el cierre de accesos a
fuentes y coberturas durante la pandemia
queda por ver si se recuperarán cuando
ésta termine
y francia empezó este lunes su desconfía
miento gradual los estudiantes de
secundaria regresan a las aulas termina
la restricción de movilidad a 10 km del
domicilio y se activan los viajes entre
diferentes regiones del país el toque de
queda sigue en vigor pero para muchos
franceses los primeros pasos suponen una
cierta sensación de alivio
un papel con el que los franceses están
muy familiarizados pero desde este lunes
ya no es necesario este documento para
justificar los desplazamientos de más de
10 kilómetros no va muy bien medirá el
próximo fin de semana para muy bien a
todo el mundo era desesperadamente
necesario
los domingos podríamos pasear más allá
de los bosques parisinos
y podremos visitar a nuestros familiares
que viven lejos
los viajes interregionales vuelven a
estar permitidos y la frecuencia de los
trenes aumentará progresivamente durante
las próximas semanas
mientras tanto 6 millones de estudiantes
de secundaria regresan a las aulas pero
con el objetivo de mantener la distancia
social en las clases algunos de ellos
seguirán la mitad de sus cursos desde
casa los centros educativos recibirán
millones de auto test que los profesores
deben hacerse dos veces por semana si
continúa siendo mejor que cerrar los
colegios por completo servían que
reflexiones y tenis osca sabemos que
cada vez que los cerramos dejamos atrás
a los estudiantes más vulnerables
y las desigualdades aumentan es el
primer paso para la reapertura gradual
de francia la siguiente fase de
desconfía miento será entre el 13 y el
17 de mayo cuando el 'toque de queda' se
retrase hasta las 9 de la noche y habrán
comercios no esenciales terrazas y
lugares culturales la comisión europea
propuso que a partir de junio los
miembros del bloque suavizan las
restricciones para viajeros no
esenciales que lleguen a la unión
europea y que estén completamente
vacunados con un fármaco autorizado
dentro del bloque
el ejecutivo comunitario añade que la
medida podría cobijar a personas con
vacunas que hayan completado el proceso
de inclusión en la lista de usos de
emergencia de la organización mundial de
la salud la medida busca favorecer el
turismo en la época de verano no
obstante son los estados miembros
quienes deben decidir sobre sus
fronteras durante la pandemia
para finalizar damos un vistazo a lo que
titula nuestra página web france24
puntocom en portada tenemos hacia el 4 m
4 de mayo 7 claves para entender las
elecciones de la comunidad de madrid' y
colombia duque retiro polémica reforma
tributaria pero busca un nuevo proyecto
fruto de consensos
a ustedes muchas gracias por su sintonía
pueden ampliar todas estas noticias en
nuestra web france24 puntocom volvemos
en breve con más
[Música]